inside of you is brought to you by vital
farms Ryan you know that feeling
the quiet satisfaction that you get when
you buy eggs that say cage-free makes
you feel good doesn't it oh yeah it's
supposed to well I hate to break it to
you Ryan but you've been duped dude oh
yeah
vital farms wants to put an end to all
the duping I should hope so
yeah vital farm eggs on the other hand
there pasture raised which is exactly
what it sounds like so the hens are
raised in a that way pasture a pasture
right the vital farm hands are treated
the way hens should be treated they have
access to the pasture all day
roaming grazing doing all the other
things that hens are supposed to do I
love vital farms always talk about their
their packaging I think it's really nice
and I just thought they had those little
eggs that they come like in a two things
so if you're on a hurry the hard-boiled
eggs they come in a little plastic bag
and it's like you know like a little zip
it's I'm a ziplock but it's like what do
you call that it's just a very pretty
look sealed sealed that's what it is
easy to open you just bring it when
you're on the way to a meeting you don't
wanna you don't wanna pass out dude it's
a nice snack I give it some salt little
pepper on there you're eating healthy
Ryan it sounds great vital farms
pasture-raised
[ __ ] free visit vital farms calm
slash coupon for two dollars off a dozen
pasture-raised eggs and look for us in
the black carton at the grocery store
that's vital farms dot-com slash coupon
for two dollars off a dozen
pasture-raised eggs and look for that
black carton at the grocery store vital
farms come on guys you're listening to
inside of U of Michael Rosenbaum hey
listen I don't care if you like hockey
or sports this is a really great story
it's it from a friend
dude this is a story about you know we
were me and this guy Chris Pronger NHL
Hall of Famer who had to retire from
many concussions and injuries known as a
tough guy was the league's Most Valuable
Player he's gonna hate me for this
probably ninety nine I think it was it
was 1990 2000 season from 2000 yeah but
just look it up won the Norris Trophy
he's won the Stanley Cup with the
Anaheim Ducks an amazing career and an
amazing story and
you know he never gets too personal and
I think he answered a lot of the
questions I've always wondered and I
think a lot of people have wondered so
we're gonna get inside a hockey player
today I want to thank you all for
listening as usual the show is I'm
loving it I'm loving it a great guest
coming up and always tweet me Instagram
me get people to keep subscribing folks
you know it helps and that's why we love
doing this for free for you right we
don't charge them do we don't know a
little bit a damn dime I know so all I
ask is hey if you like it get more
people listen to it and subscribe how
hard is it to say hey mom can you give
me your phone for a second why what do
you want with my phone oh nothing boom
boom subscribe there you going nothing
I'm saying here's mom southern I just
threw that out there yeah could've been
I'll also be at some conventions I don't
know when this is gonna air but I'll be
in New Orleans I think in January and
then more to come so check that out and
make sure you listen to in love with
Michael Rose mama Chris Sullivan we've
got a lot of great guests coming up on
that and let's get inside of the
legendary NHL Hall of Famer my friend
Bubba Chris Pronger it's my
you're listening to inside of you with
Michael Rosenbaum
[Music]
inside of you with Michael Rosenbaum was
not recorded in front of a live studio
audience
it was Mark Messier 's Queen Charlotte
Islands it was a charity fishing event
do you remember who was there as in
celebrities players hockey players it
was like all the the the Oilers Messi is
there and he brought a bunch of it was
when he had left and was in Vancouver
playing Mike Keenan Mike Keenan was
there he brought a lot of the Ranger
guys that had one cup he brought a bunch
of New York business guys with them I
remember being on a boat and I got
what's a call when you're out be sexy
sick that's the word is that what that
is
yep and I look to my left words the
words are seasick and and Isiah Thomas
is sitting in another boat and he is
he's puking I'm puking there's a bunch
and I just remembered and the rest of
you guys were hammered out to sea see
fishin that was a great trip that was a
great trip I remember a lot of great
times we were both young you you were
you're a little bit I'm two years older
you're 45 yeah yeah I remember he's at
your Hollywood age or is that's my age
you notice that girls guys they always
do that you ever while you're married to
a beautiful Lauren I was at the wedding
didn't I play a song for you guys you
did on the guitar was it was it
appropriate everything's appropriate
happy was appropriate with me yeah you
made a nice toast at the reception yeah
and you put your dad your mom and dad
Ilya Ilya hey Leila Leila
[ __ ] that Big Jim you do always [ __ ]
that up why is that cuz it's a weird
name as someone who speaks for a living
you think you'd [ __ ] em arises for a
living I don't memorize anything I just
always loved your parents to where do we
meet those do you remember where we met
we met in st. Louis remember you and
tomorrow we're doing that show and you
came in and drop the puck that's right
we came I don't think I was around the
puck because I think I was never you
were just along for the ride I was along
for the ride but I met you he didn't
really know much about hockey no I was
like and that's when he was smoking
cigars if you recall 20 cigars one in
Tom I love him but he
he always needed a vise every time he
saw know something else about a I said I
quit smoking the [ __ ] cigars now he's
drinking 27 diet cokes on a [ __ ]
plane a 40-minute flight to Seattle for
a chair very charitable guy but always
has his things God has to do hey buddy
oh my god how many pieces of nicorette
gum have you swallowed my life I think
you might as well smoke how much because
there's a Nicorette gun is it giving you
the nicotine yeah that's the idea
that's the idea yeah but you know we met
at the in st. Louis and you were young
that was and that was I wasn't playing
we stood we sat up in a box yeah because
it was I think was a preseason game it
was I think it was that's why I wasn't
playing yeah well you or maybe Ames
or maybe I was suspended actually I
might have been suspended I think you
were suspended I want to say you were
suspended I was one game I think I was
at a beautiful friendship spawned yes
you know and that's why I met you and I
met that night I remember more no Jeff
or courtroom and I member a meeting you
know there was twister and there was
Jamal Myers and there was Elvis
Jamie Rivers yeah there were who else
was that guy was a hole that was the st.
Louis team man
yeah were you one that you on the Blues
more than any other team yeah 10 years
10 years was it the best of times for
you there yeah I was a lot of fun we had
a blast there was a lot of good times a
lot of late nights I remember one night
me and your boy noodles gym club Jamie
McLennan we're coming back from our
favorite local hot spot across the river
in Western Illinois called pops still
there was there were seven still open I
haven't been there and God I don't know
how long but it we were in rush-hour
traffic going the other way I opened the
door to walk out now look I'm like oh my
god it's like oh my god and it for the
players they just love the players they
keep you guys there as long as you
wanted right they weren't kicking you
out no well actually no I think the bar
was open 24/7 so what bars open 24/7
that one was she
he's gonna go to Illinois folks and I
met you and we hit it off we started
laughing I remember doing impressions
and you were doing stuff but we just got
a kick I think we were both just young
immature guy is looking to have fun
we're kids I remember doing urban legend
you flew up to Toronto and everybody
Josh Jackson the actor you know Josh he
was just starstruck it's it's funny
because when you meet other Mighty Ducks
Fame yes of Mighty Ducks Fame and then
he went on to do other things like
Dawson's creaking with some other stuff
Ryan fringe fringe you like the fringe I
didn't watch frames did you you don't
know the fringe no I don't know
apparently was a big show yeah but I
remember him being like normally you
know if I met Jack Nicholson I'd be like
oh but with with hockey players Josh was
just enamored it's a stronger mic yeah
and when we became friends you weren't
like a big star you weren't AB like a
huge name in hockey I mean you were the
number two draft pick right correct and
I'm trying to remember but you weren't
like you hadn't taken on no no I think I
think that was the year that I was up
for the North I think that was 97 96 or
not yeah because we were about to film
we were filming the Tom show which was
ranked the worst TV show in history it
really was it was ranked 133 I'd in fact
I thought after you saw it you wouldn't
be returning my calls
okay luckily for me I didn't watch it
you really didn't you didn't watch much
like what I liked and I don't think that
was in my wheelhouse and that's what YB
became friends it was doing Forrest Gump
impressions a slap shot I was talking
stupid movies Farley that's the kind of
mentality I got you to come to Vegas to
play and the Jerry Bruckheimer
tournament we had Bubba jerseys which
look at this I'll post this oh yeah Oh
junior love it love it
signed by yeah this is 99 it's signed by
you Bob of senior and I believe that
might be Bubba Junior is that wolfy
it could be let's see a Scott wolf I
don't know but anyway look at that and
they're crazy and then I found all these
other photos oh oh and this just in
these off look at this this is me you
and me Oh
in the cup in an ass yeah I'll post that
yeah that's a good one that's you know I
snuck on the ice I was with a bunch of
the guys and I had we had press passes
to the locker room but that was it and I
went up to the guy at the ice and some
people went and I looked at the guy go
this is my brother are you really gonna
stop me here and he looked at me for a
long time I'm starting to get red
sweating I'm like it dude
Ilya Jim you [ __ ] it I like it he's this
crazy King that was a joke
Shawn yeah she's my other brother
another mother and the guy let me out
and I just started taking you know
pictures with you guys and they will get
to Anaheim we'll get to Ana time I'm in
in a time in an Atty but man we we had
so much fun I remember just in and we're
gonna get to the tee to you their nuts
and bolts I've known you so long and
I've watched your career take off you
seen mine take off you see my plummet
you know I'm doing a podcast what is he
doing I don't know but you know what's
funny is I will say this I love this
more than I think I've loved ever
anything and the reason why I think you
sort of became a fan of this show well I
don't know if you listen to it but you
were like I want to be on there yeah
which means something and I hadn't heard
feelings that you didn't invite me well
you're in st. Louis in Hara but you're
always invited open door open door
paulin door policy right but listen for
this show I've talked about it before
but for me the letters I get the the
response from people like I suffer from
mental health or I have anxiety or
depression or I had this in my life but
hearing actors who always think
everything's they had the perfect life
or sports guys you've been through ups
and downs man you went you know you were
this kid you suspended injuries
concussions jail jail I mean you've been
around and so it's like you know I was
like you know now is the perfect time
actually for you to come on because I
think whether you're you know doesn't
matter to an athlete an actor you worked
you know a regular nine-to-five job
doctor or something less important
somebody whose speeds on a microphone
and up you know an end
I love Ryan he's gonna be a huge success
and the reason I'm you know working with
him because I know he's gonna bring me
along somewhere with them you know huh I
mean if you pay me I have to pay you
gonna start you gonna start at some
point
oh yeah there's been fun yes hey don't
not much
all right so you're drafted number two
you're a guy that like first of all go
back to Dryden on Terry yes take it back
to Dryden you get an older brother Sean
who's playing he's he's getting popular
in the area from playing hockey you're
like well there's there's two of you
through let's just shoot you too yeah
and I mean did you your parents seemed
like they were good folks right yeah did
they kind of let you get away with
murder that's what I'm guessing pretty
much yeah my nickname growing up was
chaos that's it that's it
everyday everyday we either played road
hockey played hockey in the basement
played out on the outdoor rink or we're
practicing or playing down at though
every local rink what else is there to
do much every day what else is there to
on the summertime then we would go swim
and golf golfed a lot just kind of
[ __ ] around like stupid kids
and did you know what we were allowed to
be kids back then that's the beauty of
it
they just said you don't you know I'd
leave my house at 8:00 and I'd come home
at 5:00 and god knows what I was doing
and your parents never worried he's
gonna take care of himself his brothers
watching a meal ah where you gonna go
it's what are you where you gonna go
yeah what are you gonna do that's true
you might fall in a nice fishing hole or
something
no there was ice fishing there right oh
yeah great ice for sure you still go ice
fishing there no why not it's too cold
you got to drive cuz you used to want to
do that yeah I love it I love it I go
snowmachining do all the fun stuff it's
great
so you Soph no too soft your parents so
they let you go now Jim was a drinker
right
not really no he wasn't because I always
remember one story about your dad the
story of the olive oil I was his buddy
that was dawn that wasn't him no that
was dawn I remember we were at dinner
go ahead all right we're at dinner local
Italian joint and Clayton where I lived
and me and Yura dinner was my dad and
his friend Don and Don's crushed from
this after a game Don's crushed and he
keeps trying to grab his drink but
really it's the bottle of olive oil for
the bread and I keep pushing away go Don
no and he keeps having it and I push it
away go Don no finally I move it over
different part of the table and then me
and you start talking and I kind of
forget about him and sure enough I look
over and he's chugging this olive oil
I'm like oh my god never forgot I
obviously didn't forget by the way that
night he got up at like 4:00 in the
morning to take a [ __ ] and broke the
toilet and somehow figured out a way to
turn the water off in his broke the
toilet from I don't know if he like
dropped down on it or leaned back too
hard the toilet [ __ ] broke and yet he
had the wits about him to turn the water
off at the bottom did your you and your
dad ever get into any kind of
altercations cuz I noticed like you're a
hockey player Shawn Zaki play your dad's
a big guy he's like you know did you
ever get into things where you're like
you hey cuz I know you I know you have
you're a hothead sometimes and you like
things done your way whether you're
playing or whether you're control freak
like me at times you like things your
way did ever occur to you like you
stepped over the line you like you yeah
[ __ ] that my dad I know that happened I
want you to tell me a story that you
recall where you and Jimbo got into it
he only got mad at me twice like where
he was pissed where I was like oh [ __ ]
I'm dead how old were you I was 14 maybe
that what happened how tall are you at
14 I was 6
one maybe sixty thought I'm cool
no I just know I was I did so I can't
remember what I did but he was pissed
and he came firing home and was like
[ __ ] sat me down is like I don't ever
want to [ __ ] and see who do that first
time you ever swore at me - it really
was so mad are you scared I was just
like holy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] dead here I
swear I got up when I stood around
behind the couch so I could get out of
the way I was like holy [ __ ] he's pissed
but never like a smack right no ma'am no
my mom was usually the disciplinarian
she'd spank you she would spank me and
then she used to hit me with the wooden
spoon but when I was eight I clinched
the borough butt cheek and their spoon
broke and I turn round sir laughing at
her and that was the end of that I'm
doing squats [ __ ] no I mean but you're
already like straw a strong kid I mean
you grew so fast did you know you're
gonna do something did you no no you
know what I always tell people they
don't you know I'm super small-town
middle of middle of nowhere no internet
no friggin nothing you don't even know
like I used to get the hockey digest and
the hockey news once a week that's the
only hockey information I had we only
got Hockey Night in Canada one night a
week on Saturdays there was no other
hockey games on TV so that's it that's
why we're outside we're outside everyday
so that's why Canadians more Canadians
make it to the NHL than any other
country well but that's changing that I
think Canada is like 45% in the league
now what is a slow hockey or some [ __ ]
no us is 25% it's the it's score yeah
it's shifting the tides are shifting
tides so really that all you could do
was go outside and play and play hockey
and do whatever I mean but but do you
think about it I mean we're outs you're
outside you're being a kid you're
outside you're screwing around with your
friends I think we had a close-knit
group of friends whom you've met that we
all lived you know oh you're not like
you're living too far anywhere in town
but we all live fairly close we all
congregate it your parents knew where
you worried they know who you were with
you know and there they were friends
with their parents right so you know it
was all it was easy yeah do you see
growing up easy yeah but I never had any
information on anybody that my age that
played down in Toronto or played out in
Vancouver or Calgary or any of the bit
Montreal any of the big cities in Kent I
don't know who they were I didn't know
anybody and then I went to a camp down
in I think it was Guelph where all
Guelph that's in Ontario it's about a
hour and a half from Toronto and really
just started to see these kids I didn't
know how good I was I didn't know you
know you don't really know you play in
the local tournaments you know we
borrowed Swede go as Winnipeg you play
against some kids but you don't really
know but did anybody go that promo kid
you know the giant was I was always from
my age group I was always a better best
kid on the team you know I played up a
little bit you know I was one of the
better kids
I think being tall you have that allure
or that aura of oh he's big
I was skin and bones but I was tall were
you soft were you always tough I was
mean I liked altercations like you know
I mean I I fought a little bit but I
didn't
I fought when I needed to but I didn't
fight all the time I didn't you know I
was playing so much that it's tiring and
nobody want the wrassling around that's
around that's tiring anybody did like
when you were younger did people even
pick fights with you they're gonna take
the big guy down uh yeah sometimes did
you ever get taken down oh you got to
pick your battles I didn't you know
that's a smart player will always pick
his battles one of the things that I
know the best I know who's on the ice at
all times I know who's coming on the ice
I know who's leaving the ice I know
matchups I know who's behind your highs
around I know everything I know
everything that's going on that's
something that was just natural to you
or did you really have to learn that
because that's multitasking
I mean it's sense it's awareness you
know some of its hockey cents some of
it's awareness and knowing what's going
on around you know street smarts
all that [ __ ] plays into it I think but
I think just always knowing and
understanding
your role understanding your matchup
understanding what you have to do to be
successful what you got to do to win I
just wanted to win right you know and
there's some hurt feelings at times for
you and I just want to win no you a
crier when you were a kid it seems to me
like you're like there's those kids
they're so full of anger and so full of
emotion that if something didn't happen
you go back and you start crying not at
a young I would fly off the handle I
wouldn't I don't know if I cried a ton
you break your stick you throw [ __ ] oh
yeah I got ball of [ __ ] yeah well I
remember you playing hockey with you I
think it was you and Jack your little
Jack yeah we had the same birthday you
and him al McGinnis and myself yeah al
McGinnis one of the best slap shots ever
and I'll keep you want to look him up
google him but I remember we were just
taking some soft shots on goal he was
playing goalie and if you let a [ __ ]
goal and go don't [ __ ] score on him
yeah I mean and he's a big one now too
huh yeah he's six seven he's six foot
seven jack yeah and he's obviously what
we're it was he playing he's playing
basketball he just said no to hockey uh
he was playing and then it was good he
was all right and then he just you don't
he kept growing
you know it's awkward and he's playing
high school hockey nope he's not playing
hockey at all all right elavil I'm sorry
to ask you ball yeah he's playing high
school basketball so is George and
George George is six too now George's a
little turd
he's Ella Dylan he might who Lyla Lyla
[ __ ] you're [ __ ] up every name are
you nice [ __ ] it's hard with all those
names she's probably five feet doing her
art and tennis and she's easy to the
bunch she's an old soul it's nice to get
to we're gonna get to all the dirt and
stuff because you know you talked about
growing up now dirt when I say dirt it's
just like you know people look I wrote
some [ __ ] down like I I know you so to
speak you know I don't know exactly how
to pronounce your mom's [ __ ] name Ted
so well you know it's been years cuz we
really hung out a long time a lot and
then you know you and then you got
famous
no no well that's my hit that's not true
but I was in Vancouver ten months a year
for seven years I well but then you
got married obviously and you had a
family and you started playing and
things you started changing the team's
reply to the Anaheim Ducks to the Flyers
some would say to the Coyotes but that's
sort of true I mean look we both went
our separate ways but I was always like
man I do miss those times the Proms I do
miss those you know times with you know
MacLennan was the the coach Joel
McLennan know Joel Quenneville
Quenneville Jamie McLennan you are
having a tough goal right now we'll edit
that out huh let's start again Joel
Quenneville right know who's your coach
yeah he's a great coach and I love
Quenneville I remember Krenzel seeing me
come to your some of your games on the
road or whatever and he'd see me show up
to the like you know we go back to the
hotel because we're gonna go out he look
at me go hey this is on you you're in
charge you know take the big guy down
like nobody's in charge of him I
remember going in in Toronto when you
came up for urban legend we went to a
bar and some guy was just trying to be a
hothead some guy was just trying to go
all there's Chris Pronger NHL star he's
a tough guy he's like yeah [ __ ] you and
you're like yeah bud come on you didn't
let's not do this you were trying to do
the right thing but then you had another
a couple couple of drinks and you like
yeah you know what [ __ ] you let's go
outside and I'm like no no no we're not
gonna do this that was you know you
gotta remember I was 20 to 20 suitors
old no I was like 23 other oh yeah
you're younger than me so yeah you're
your kid what I'm saying is you're a kid
at the time but this guy started with
you did you have a lot of that where
guys would just start shooting I'm you
know what not a ton I think as we age
you figure out life you figure things
out I think a lot of times early on like
once I turned pro 18 19 20 21 it was a
little awkward where people they want to
say something it always comes out bad oh
and I don't like people staring at me so
they're staring at you
they don't know what to say something
like what the [ __ ] your problem you
know like they're they're kind of I
don't start struck whatever you don't
even know that they're just start oh no
they're just they're staring at you like
kind of awkwardly and you're like what
the [ __ ] is your problem when you're
young you don't realize you did a lot of
that yeah and and I did anyway
no I never got in any fights you never
got the rights away no did you always
hang around other guys that would fight
no I never I've never been the only the
only and I wasn't even a fight the only
time anything like that ever had at all
the alleged brawl in Buffalo so it
wasn't a brawl got suspended no I didn't
get suspended they couldn't because we
were it was like mid to late March
Boston and Buffalo were fighting it out
for a playoff spot there was nine of us
in the bar and they was at twister no no
this is when I was in Hartford but there
was nine of you yeah we uh we spent the
night in jail
and you didn't hit one person no nobody
on our side touched a soul I was
actually being the peacemaker what well
there was freaking six bouncers coming
at us and we're like hey relax what I'm
coming at you they didn't swing punt
they throw punch I step they're stepping
forward we'd step back they step forward
we step back we're like hey we'll leave
you don't want wanted to fight you yeah
we're scared no a little no because then
the guy kept pushed and kept pushing I'm
like all right listen stop please stop
we'll leave and then he started chirpin
more and you're like all right finally
you're like okay [ __ ] it let's go then
and then the cops came busting in so
they had called the cops cops come
busting in we didn't there was no
punches thrown on our side they were
getting maced we're getting or you know
they amazed yeah the cops the cops
you got maced my I couldn't figure out I
was trying to figure out I'm like man
why is my ear so sore cuz they started
and I burns
I turned and my whole ear was raw and I
was like what the hell is wrong with my
ear and then I remember I'm like oh [ __ ]
I got maced what another player got they
cuffed and then they maced him like it
was a total disgrace and this was in
Buffalo yeah did you hate Buffalo to
this day for that I do I do
she's got a bad taste in it every time
I'm there I break out in hives but no I
just it I just you don't like it out I'm
in and out if I gotta be there I'm there
in my room I I'm not going out I'm not
I'm just I'm done you know would be fun
why don't you and I take a trip to that
bar back in Buffalo see what's happening
after all he's that that [ __ ]
you know what you know what the funniest
mom it's funny now but then we're in the
bar the bar is right across the street
from the police station they put us in
police cars and [ __ ] drove us around
the [ __ ] City laughing and chirping
us I mean it was wow I didn't even know
the cop shop was across the street I
went back to her and later I'm like what
the well didn't they get reprimanded
today would never write an article about
the police Buffalo
no but that's pretty [ __ ] up they
don't get a rise out of you guys yeah
and they wanted to beat on my we didn't
we didn't take the bait but you still
got maced you still got arrested yeah
does it still piss you off to this day
yeah it does it does yeah and then so
one of the bouncers kicked a guy and
broke his toe so who do you think got
suit and you had to pay it no [ __ ] no I
and I it was like two or three years
later all of a sudden you get served
with a lawsuit like lawsuit for what
pain and suffering guy broke his toe
cheap shouting a guy when he was on the
ground and we're gonna give him money no
did you had to pay for your drinks no oh
good I mean I know you probably had a
lot so then you were traded from
Hartford obviously everyone knows the
story for Shanahan right yep you get
traded to the blues yeah and that's when
the real and I remember reading articles
along the way like Keenan was like oh
he's inpatient he's immature I mean
you're young you're 25 or 25 oh honey
20 I got when I got traded there I was
20 I mean I don't know how you do it if
you look back it's just like yeah of
course well you know the the funny part
in the stupid part as
and then growing up an adult and
understanding a lot more you just wish
what you know now you could have known
then but why then you don't have those
memories stupid memories a lot of stupid
memory don't make those mistakes you
know they always say you know I so it
makes you Michael what it's what makes
you what makes you Ryan mold you yeah
you don't look you do much stupid [ __ ]
in your life no you know I keep it good
yeah you have a good head on your
shoulders
yeah this is screwed on pretty tight yes
it looks like it is he's mature let me
tell you it hurts it does yeah I could
see that yeah Spielberg said I've quoted
this he's the most immature person there
is believe it or not Steven Spielberg
says he's the most immature but he's
incredibly responsible and those two
things it's okay if you're responsible
immature and irresponsible you're [ __ ]
you are [ __ ] right Kashan had a
successful career he went to the NHL he
wrote a book great guy smart guy good
hockey player
was there any brother jealousy issues
ever growing up whatever like he was big
brother and then all of a sudden you
became the MVP Norris Trophy winner no I
think when you you look at and you ask
me about growing up and dried
he left when I got to high school he
left to go play junior hockey and
Thunder Bay so we even go to high school
together
pretty bummed a little bit I think you
know where you're you you want to have
that experience but you know there was
the the friendly brotherly rivalry right
you know where you're competing your as
a younger brother you're always trying
to you know I I truly believe that was a
big part of my success was always
playing against bigger stronger kids
older kids you know you got to keep up
that scene in Youngblood where he goes
out there the older brother teaches him
how to fight yeah did that ever happen
with you and Asha no no is that you
think that there's any truth to that
scene I mean it was there ever a moment
where you like I gotta learn how to
fight it someone teach you to fight that
you take boxing lesson though you just
gotta throw a punch well I think you're
new to tuck your
very calm around the piss I'm a very
visual learner
you'll learn real quick how to play
defense or at least I did I don't know
too many guys that like getting punched
in the face No so there are some that do
but do you at all like getting punch in
the face
do you like punching people in the face
it felt pretty good back in the day yeah
yeah what's one fight that you remember
just in the NHL that you punched someone
boy that feel [ __ ]
I fought Todd Simpson in Calgary one
night this is 96 it might have been my
big year I'm trying to think where he
was caught cocking off and Posey say him
I don't we just acted tough and it was
we're in a big scrum and I don't I don't
necessarily think he thought I was gonna
fight so there was two fights going on I
was one of them there was another one
going on and I was like well then let's
go he was sacked and tough and I'm like
okay let's go then boom gloves came off
I'm like I'm not gonna not gonna wait
for him so then I dropped my gloves he
said oh my god you suckered me I'll go I
did not
I go you you wanted a fight I said let's
go then there's one punch no no no no no
it was a good fight you know I hit him
with a good laughs that kind of buckled
him I think it would kind of surprise
them because he tried to switch and then
I switch and hit him first with my left
and he's like oh now roll ready do you
think that uh you know a lot of times
players in the NHL especially people
don't understand this billion I hate
hockey the fight it's so stupid I'm like
you don't understand you have to be a
part of it it's imagine being as intense
and competitive as you possibly can and
the hits and this and that and something
happens you could change the the outcome
of a game by getting the crowd into it
getting it and and you get into this
fight and then afterwards even though it
seems like these two people hate each
other isn't it true that hockey players
can go to a bar and go hey what's up you
know I think when fighting is about the
emotion and the mental and physical
aggression that trying to win at all
costs and you know your your anger gets
better if you really alright [ __ ] it
let's go you know those are the ones
where you just can see the passion
between the two guys and like okay I get
it
the stage fighting I was never a big fan
of it you know I didn't really serve up
too much of a purpose you know and then
they're obviously you get the guys that
need to come home like hey settle down
the big boys come on go settle down and
you're like okay and you can just feel
the temperature just kiei things are
calming down just a teensy bit but you
know you two guys bowing in front of the
net or in the corner and you know all of
a sudden you hit the guide either too
hard or you punch over the back of the
head or you know whatever you stick them
in the groin slashing behind the knee or
the other way the devil come on or
whatever whatever some happens and then
it's you know it's all about the emotion
and an aggression of that particular
moment well some people would say hey
prong is one of the dirtiest players
that ever lived I listened I wanted a
win that's it so if people have a
problem with it my teammates didn't have
a problem so you know it's it's again
you're one of those guys where you
people love to hate you but they want
you on their team yeah so I'm good with
it
chippy ya chippy yes did your coaches
ever say prongs mmm I need you in this
game well keep back down Wow and that
goes back to fighting and some of the
you know stuff I'm like yes the coaches
would be like hey we need you on the ice
you know it starts get chipping like hey
don't get into a fight or don't do this
there are moments where they try to
curtail your aggression you know
depending upon the game and situations
etc but for the most part no they you
play how you play and you just got to
kind of live with it yeah did you ever
feel like I lost the game for us tonight
I got that penalty no three minutes left
we had the chance I got the penalty
never know what you're gonna you're
gonna they're gonna be moments where you
take those but if we're winning the game
or tie like that I'm not necessarily
looking for something like that you know
trying to catch a guy coming across in
Miller I'm not trying to take a guy out
in the corner too hard
if you do something that's an accident
trying to save somebody break away yeah
I mean you get to do what you got to do
sometimes but I never I never look I
would leave a game if I did if I thought
I didn't play good I'd be pissed off at
myself and you know I think as I aged I
learned to leave the game and that game
at the rink but early on in my career
man I'd frickin there'd be games it
would last a week all right like [ __ ]
I didn't play very good and I've already
played three more games since then what
that is that's a little anxiety you you
had anxiety
I mean how did you deal did you I guess
drinking right I guess you'd go after a
game and you want to get I didn't you
know what I didn't I really didn't drink
a ton during a season you know you'd get
you'd get the three days in between
games and obviously there's a flashing
green light after that last game you got
three days off so you're gonna have time
to recover you're gonna go have a good
time right but I really I picked my
spots and I really didn't drink a ton
during the season did you did you or
were you intimidated of any there was
was there one player or a couple players
only when you play them you're like [ __ ]
like intimidating in a sense that
they're too good or they're gonna get
they're gonna get around me everyone
smile or no I didn't I think you go into
those situations with the awareness of
how good they are and with the idea of
pre scouting you know back again this is
before the ridiculous amount of video
that these guys do now you were just
watching tape I'm watching yeah I'm
watching tape or I'm watching highlights
and seeing the different moves that they
have so that hey okay oh I just saw him
make this so when he cuts this way he's
gonna try this move you're just banking
all this stuff up in the old rolodex up
top and you know should you should you
get into that situation you have an idea
of the different moves that they can
make or try on you and usually usually
gonna be able to stop them but there was
moments where you're like holy [ __ ] this
guy's pretty good
who was players that you just thought
wow these guys are great these are great
they're hard to play against I don't
look forward to playing and somewhere
maybe you did yeah I like playing again
I mean
that's where you kind of test yourself
that's I like plants by playing with the
bigger guys back younger right like you
want to test yourself you wanna you're
only gonna get better playing against
the best players but who are they to you
who are the players while that you
thought well the best oh they they were
at the time you know you look at the
Russian five I'm actually gon that I
think it's the Red Army or the Russian
one of those movies that they just made
yeah for some yeah yeah I'm in I think
it's the Red Army one I'm in there just
getting worked over real Erik Tac Tic
Tac Toe I'm like [ __ ] why do you pick
that clip yeah Hegel thinking about the
ginyu yeah exactly I'm like [ __ ] I
remember that I was brutal I mean so
those guys especially I remember when
the Blues could never get past Detroit
yeah I remember going to those games I
remember with no time left McGinnis for
the Blues fires that slap shot I think
from half ice and it goes in and ties
the game and you guys just got so close
with those [ __ ] Red Wings but you
couldn't get him right how frustrating
was that it was a thorn in my side it
was that did those those losses
especially when you see them to go on
and win it grinds on you euros and
you're always getting the questions
what's wrong with you guys why can't you
beat him why can't you do this why can't
you know that everybody's always
second-guessing everybody's a [ __ ]
armchair quarterback cuz it's so [ __ ]
easy
[Laughter]
it's an incredibly hard sport yeah and
intense and you're playing at high
speeds best athletes in the world and
you're going down the line and what
sucks probably for you is like you knew
that if the Blues would have won those
games or won that series they probably
would have won the Stanley Cup or has a
good chance yes absolutely and that's
what hurts the most
yeah and we had some really good teams
it's uh just yeah they the losses eat me
up more than the winds of course I mean
yeah I mean there's nothing better than
winning
I just hate lose
more than I love winning it hurts more
to lose than it does feeling great to
win yeah that's my mindset and other
people you know they can slough off the
losses it's easy for them and just for
me it was never easy inside of you is
brought to you by Warby Parker took the
SPN guy it kind of sounded like the
brought to you by Michelob Ultra dude
Warby Parker look when you think like
glasses right I wear I wear glass I'm
wearing them right now okay
I'm wearing my Warby Parker's right now
for the listeners for the listeners I'm
telling you right now I I never wanted
to shop online for glasses cuz you think
you think you know I just want to go
inside I'm gonna try them on and then I
want to spend $3,000 more than a plane
ticket for prescription lenses in there
that's not how this works and I'm glad
they forced me to take a quiz because I
wouldn't have done at my lazy-ass and it
took no time at all Ryan I ordered five
glasses five pairs of glasses ago I like
that one I like that one up to five
right yeah I tried them on for five days
I asked Jess in there Jess which one you
like there's no obligation to buy
shipping is free and includes a prepaid
return shipping label you pick the
glasses they send you five glasses and I
guarantee you're gonna like one you
might even want to glasses start at $95
including prescription lenses you're not
gonna find that and they they look great
I don't know that what else did say here
they look good they you know you go one
of these fancy ass stores and you're
gonna spend four or five hundred dollars
guys you need help with glasses do what
I did take the quiz don't be lazy answer
a few questions
they'll suggest some great looking
glasses that are totally personalized to
fit your face your style free home try
on program like I talked about they're
gonna send you glasses it's got a return
prepaid shipping label on it that you
just send it back here's what I want you
to do head to Warby Parker dot-com slash
IOU you take the quiz if you order your
free home trial it's that easy
and you're gonna be happy and you're
going to thank
you just need to do this because they're
badass
they got sunglasses starting at $95 and
for every pair of glasses sold Warby
Parker distributes a pair of glasses to
someone in need blue light filter lenses
are now available
Warby Parker believes glasses should be
viewed as a fashion accessory just like
a bag a shoe a necktie a hat they make
it easy and affordable to accessorize
with glasses hey tell them what happens
if they have an iPhone X you can
download Warby Parker's app yeah and you
know then you can see their what they're
they got a brand new virtual Tryon yeah
you could try on your glasses on on the
phone yeah you could see the realistic
color texture the size of each style
using just your phone order the free
home try on program or request a trial
of scout contact lenses for just $5
visit Warby Parker comm slash iou to
learn more inside of you is brought to
you by Stan's you know how much I love
Stan's
I have so many pairs of their socks and
what sucks is I bought all these socks
before they were my sponsor I've spent
thousands of dollars I have so many Star
Wars socks Major League Baseball I got
freaking wu-tang socks Ryan they're
badass they're comfortable my listeners
right now listen up it's Christmas for
God's sakes you're gonna love these
things you got a boyfriend you got a
girlfriend you got a sister a mother a
nephew this is a great stocking stuffer
my listeners get a free pair of socks
with their next order period all you got
to do is go to Stan's comm slash I owe
you that Stan's comm slash I owe you you
get a free pair of socks I honestly Ryan
can you think of a better gift or
something to give him the holiday then
Stan's socks socks a great gift now my
god they're great I wore him on the
plane I just got home I had a 21 hour
flight I had a I had Knicks socks you
know Knicks are like the New York
knickerbockers
that's exactly Basketball Association
that's exactly right they've got any
anything you want you get you think
you're a fan of like you're a fan of
Disney or Marvel or Major League
Baseball NFL this the movie stepbrothers
they got socks for everybody the quality
and detail that goes into Stan
socks is incredible the design range
from simple to elaborate with a ton of
insanely cool collaborations like I
talked about it's just it's really a
great product design comfort casual
everyday style is like no shows and crew
socks or performance athletic products
look they're the official on-field sock
of Major League Baseball you know the
Red Sox with Major League Baseball
supports them no I'm saying so where
they get Ryan they get a free pair of
socks
they do sign up right now do your thing
get a free pair of socks with your next
order all you got to do is go to Stan's
sta NCE like pants Stan's comm slash IOU
Stan's dot-com slash IOU inside of you
is brought to you by tashi this is just
something that everyone needs you know
you want to go to those fancy Plitt well
I don't go to fancy places but I've seen
like friends you know rich friends that
have those bad days that are you know it
squirts up in your ass and it cleans
your ass and it's nice and all that
stuff but they're now their fortune or
paying the ass no pun intended
well this is a product that you don't
need a lot of money to have a clean ass
everyone has an ass Ryan I assume you
have an ass I do have an ass yeah yeah
yeah well everyone deserves the gift of
tishy
okay wiping your ass with dry toilet
paper it doesn't mean I'm gonna be
Google graph it doesn't remove all the
crap it just doesn't right that's why
you get like hemorrhoids people get like
UTIs they get because it there's
bacteria left there plus you wipe so
hard your ass bleeds I mean I'm getting
graphic but this this thing is a badass
look wet wipes you know people I would
use those wet wipes on my butt rather
than 12-bit but you know what that's
terrible for the environment you got to
do something for the environment and
they cause anal fissures you don't want
your anus fishery wasn't you're not
fishery that's Saturday that's the sound
of a fishery $79 it helps you get
everything out I love these things
because they look cool they're easy to
put on to your freaking toilet it cleans
your butt and if you're a listener of
iou inside of you you get ten percent
off your order you go - hello - she calm
and by the way I'm on their site now
look at it they've got so much
little [ __ ] here gift bundles they got
the clean but club I mean they got it's
really a fun site to go on and look
through stuff and shop great for
Christmas
you know ornaments stocking stuffers but
this tushy thing it sprays your ass with
fresh water not toilet water I think
that's the big misconception Ryan oh
it's not toilet water no - she connects
to the Whorton it connects to the water
supply behind you - so you you spray
your dirty parts with clean fresh water
it's the same water you brush your teeth
with except you're cleaning your ass
with this clean water I've said enough
go - hello - she calm all right hello -
she calm / I owe you
hello tissue calm / I owe you 10 percent
off your butt
how grateful are you are you able to be
grateful has it taken time to take a
step back I once read something there's
an article in Sports Illustrated
southern about you a couple years ago or
whatever and how you went through such a
hard time because you know you had the
concussions and you had the eye injury
you went through [ __ ] hell with the
eye thing I mean hell I know how bad you
wanted to get back I know how you know
how hard you fought to get back but you
know you had limitation yeah there's
something that you know just was this
his life yeah and when how hard was it
to finally accept that did you have to
go through therapy did you have to like
will you say hey I'm [ __ ] like you're
hurting your family inadvertently where
you a pain in the ass to be around were
you miserable the first year when I
first got hurt I remember like three or
four days into being hurt I was sat in
my room in the dark for nine days and
you know I'd try to get up take a leak
in the middle of the night I'm falling
into walls I'm all over the place
well why just like my head I couldn't
concussion yeah I just couldn't catch my
bearings
how scary is that well at the time
you're not you're probably a little bit
out of it but you're also just trying to
get back so yeah I just always used to
push off my nice are well you don't
worry about it you know oh my head start
on just don't worry about it you know
you just try to push this stuff aside
he's down at the game to be fine yeah
throw a little ice on it whatever rub
some ointment on it he'll be fine it'll
be good you're fine you know I just
always had that old-school mindset of
mind over matter just [ __ ] don't
worry about it it's not it'll it'll go
away or you know it always has gone away
before it'll go away
you know I get my bell rung a few times
I always went away you know and just
this one kind of stuck there and hung
around and hung around and what year was
this ah 2011 yeah it just wouldn't go
away well I just I was getting nauseous
and driving like I had to drive my car
at night with shades on cuz the lights
coming at me bothered a living hell out
of me so I'm driving around my car my
shades so you can't even think of
playing and I used to go over the bridge
over to the game rink and you know
do I used to get so freakin nauseous
just that you can remember it now like
it so I could see you feeling awful oh
yeah just start and get sick to your
stomach and then your head gets all
[ __ ] up and I go on then you're
showing off at the rank you like I'm
going on [ __ ] this you know like
ultimately when I when I told you no
when I went to see the doctor and oh my
god you're done he said that yeah you
say what was like how the [ __ ] are you
playing because I I was playing so I
came back and I played five games and
then I was off why mean I just wasn't
myself and I was nauseous a little
nauseous on the bench you know my eyes
were the bright lights were bothering me
I had a headache you know all of all the
symptoms but again I was just like yeah
[ __ ] it it'll go away and I was actually
getting worse not better
and it was bothering me more and more
funny I'm told the trainer I gonna
something's wrong he [ __ ] see the
doctor so the doctor I see the doctor
and she's like wow we got to send you to
Pittsburgh and go see the concussion guy
and I get there and I see him and he's
looking at my file and you know you fill
out the forms how many concussions have
you had I'm like I'm [ __ ] know 100
when you think about it when you're a
kid you're banging your head on the wall
well that's you know when you're seeing
stars you start trying to understand
what is a concussion what is the medical
term and what is the medical diagnosis
of what is a concussion there's so many
different I'm seeing start you know
think about back to when I blacked out I
blacked out and I'm seeing stars I got a
stinger I got a you know you know I got
hit one night in LA here
friggin stu bright lights right you
would never know it was an innocuous hit
just hit me in the jaw kind of coming
across really quick it was quick we both
fell and then you were five was I was
right beside our bench I'm like huh [ __ ]
I'm like oh my god as soon as I open my
eyes [ __ ] two bright lights coming
out and I thank God I was right beside
the our bench I just stepped onto the
bench sat down I call the trainer who
dude I got two bright lights you know
this is like mid-90s
Danny's I go huh okay well yo can you
play and I'm like yeah I'm good I can
just i sat back in the rock
chair and just kind of use my peripheral
vision and look kind of lifted my head
up so the bright lights weren't straight
ahead where everybody was I just kind of
lift him Jesus you weren't sure at all
me I'm out you don't know any [ __ ]
better yes that's I play Augie it's what
I do and you know you're the I think was
in the playoffs oh you're just playing
you not really paying attention a lot of
that stuff I mean that's terrifying like
I'm hearing this and like but but when
you went to that doctor for the first
time or not to fall yeah so did get back
to that yeah he he looks at my file and
he looks at kind of looking at me
checking me out and he comes back he's
like how are you playing you you were
just you just played I go yeah I played
five games he's like what the hell were
you doing you should not people I think
I go huh okay I mean ever I'm like what
he's like you're you can't play anymore
you're not just like that oh well you're
kind of like well you know we'll see you
know you're like that was a party that
goes my god I think he's right what if
he is well when you never really go
through your whole file you're not going
through all your home at this point I've
had 13 surgeries on your I know no 13
surgeries I'm all you're me my body my
back my knee my wrist my hand all the
different things my foot all the
different stuff and you're like okay
you're looking at that [ __ ] files
like this thick and you're like mmhmm
yeah maybe this time I don't know do I
really can my body really take this
pounding canned it really and do you
while your head Wow now your heads all
[ __ ] up and you're like my I was
[ __ ] up my head was [ __ ] up where is
it gonna end
you know now Lauren's like what are you
thinking about here I'm like I don't
know and then the doctor it's almost
like he did me a favor it's like you're
done and then and then you know what and
then ed Snider the owner of the flyers
you know his his son-in-law is a doctor
so he shows him the file in the son was
like I was it how's this guy playing the
disc I can't play he had the same
diagnosis he's my god this guy can't
play dad the owner is probably thought
no he was awesome
well he wasn't saying [ __ ] he's got four
more years no he was awesome he was the
best health as well my friend he was the
best he was like then you're done you're
done you know did you did you get
emotional do you think you ever have you
still a hit you even like look I know
you you're the kind of guy that look I
don't cry in front of people I mean
maybe a little bit only on yet only at
your movie premieres yes well afterwards
[Laughter]
let me ask you something I know you
prongs you're a tough guy and I got a
little surprise surprise for you in a
second but the guys that know ya the
guys that have seen ya you're tough as
nails you're giving I remember just
going to the the all-star the NHL
all-star game with you afterwards you
got jerseys for everybody signed by
everybody you got me the katene Canada
Jersey signed you threw it to me through
it to Daddy through to your friends you
got them all signed you went in there
you're the you're a giving guy you're
always there you're [ __ ] you're funny
you're impatient as [ __ ] but uh burn but
I yes stubbornness [ __ ] that yeah the
most stubborn but I've just never seen
you you know and maybe you'd do this
behind closed doors I just can't eat it
with Lauren it's probably hard you're
just a tough guy you've grown up to be
tough you're six foot six you're a
[ __ ] you're like you know when Quint
is talking about the shark in Jaws it's
an eating machine he's the [ __ ] you
know his eyes roll over black
he's eyes like a doll's eyes you know is
there ever a moment where you the
superhuman prongs just goes I don't know
for me it's like watching a rocky scene
for the movie Rocky in my basement alone
and just like the tears start coming and
I get the emotions out or is there ever
an emotional moment where you cried to
Lauren or you cried and said I just I
need to let this out ya know I you know
what I never felt sorry for myself I had
a long career and I did everything that
I could you know what to say it said
Sidney Crosby was going through the same
thing at the same time and you try to
compare and at the time you're like he
was
twenty-four or whatever he was and
you're like at that age you're like
that's a lot to be given up you know
people cuz people were taught well maybe
you should retire maybe I'm like no
that's uh
time's up just like that it is you know
there are moments where you're sitting
at home and you're watching the game and
you're like [ __ ] if I was there that if
I was there that wouldn't happen or if I
was there we would have won that game or
you know I look back though I'm like
you'll watch a clip from Anaheim when
you're holding the cup up because tears
of joy to your eyes you know what more
relief relief that you were finally able
to to win it you know cuz every player
like thing about Ray Bourque at 40
every player that's what they were when
they're up it's the Holy Grail but the
whole world gauges well how many cups
does he want
well not everybody has a chance to play
with the Red Wings in the 90s or play
with the friggin Black Hawks they're
like it's rare it's rare so you get guys
oh my god he's a five-time ever play
with the Oilers in the 80s like holy
[ __ ] how many they won six five five
five I shouldn't one six remember them
well yeah yeah yeah
for me it was more a sense of relief
that whole that's one I can knock off
the list where you like cuz it's so
[ __ ] hard to win yeah so much has to
go right you got it there's a little bit
of luck you know the injury bug and and
all the different things that kind of
play into it the goalie or goalies got
to be hot you got to get timely Scarman
there's just so many pieces to the
puzzle goalies quit really crazy would
you see every goal you play what they
got to be a little crazy right well you
have to be grant Fuhrer was crazy
Yeah right [ __ ] wants to stand in front
of I you know it's so funny you're like
I would never want to be a goalie but
yet I'll stand in front of a hundred
mile an hour
slap shot to block it but I'm not
putting on those [ __ ] pads and that's
right it's just I find it
amusingly odd that I'm okay with that
but I don't want to go in there with all
that [ __ ] on well let's go to that you
uh was I thinking no I don't think I was
at that game I was at one of those games
in that series it was with Detroit where
the heart stopped you got hit in the
chest with a puck yeah I don't know if
anybody and my let my listeners will
most of them they're not I went to
doctors hands are they doctors it might
be doctors okay do you know what it's
called the medical term for what
happened to me is called kimochi o
cordis commercial cordis
cordis it happens a lot to little league
baseball players where the guys standing
at third or the pitcher and they get hit
with a line drive and it hits them right
in the heart and what happens is their
heart stops my heart so I blocked a slap
shot it hit me right on the heart my
heart skipped one beat one one and I
that's all it took you just clap that's
how much oxygen and how much [ __ ]
happens in your body with one heartbeat
in a split second I got hit down I got
hit and I'm like [ __ ] that hurt and I'm
thinking in my head and you know I go
down cover the puck and I'm like do not
let these [ __ ] people see you on the
ground so in my head I'm like get the
[ __ ] up and get to the bench and I kind
of stumble up and black out and I in the
video you could see me stand up and I
start going towards a match and then
boom thank God I had my hands in front
of me or I would have did the Kevin
Stevens and faceplant and broke my face
but I kind of crumbled down on the side
and hit my ear a little bit another ear
one where I woke up and I'm like [ __ ] my
ear sore somebody was on the [ __ ] ice
that Todd Simpson and then I remember
waking up and I'm looking up and I'm
like holy [ __ ] I'm in the middle of the
rink what I'm looking up but all these
Red Wings banners and I'm like it was a
playoff game yeah well game is this this
is a game - and then I then I look down
and my jerseys cut open my shoulder pads
are ripped apart and I'm like what the
[ __ ] and I look over in our bench I'm
looking at Holly's crying on the bench
and everybody's like the black hole
Brett Hall yeah the whole place is like
silent you could hear a pin drop and I'm
just like what the hell and then man I'm
not married at the time my parents are
at the game oh would mrs. Prager would
Chris's wife please come down to the to
the Zamboni entrance because they had
the ambulance there for me and I'm
listening I'm like huh
I'm married it's my parents house that
that wedding was soon after I mean you
could have died like that right so
most kids when they get it they die
because their hearts not formed long
enough they're not strong enough they
die I just happened to I don't know you
got a lot of yeah a lot of people but
again to go back to you know we're
talking about playing hurt whatever I'm
[ __ ] dumb I'm 22 or 23 at the time
I'm dumb I don't know anything I go into
the hospital they put a heart monitor on
me they they watch my heart for 2014
they watched my heart for 24 hours I fly
home I'm in my frickin suit in my rut
and my dress shoes get on a treadmill
with the heart specialist in st. Louis I
get on this treadmill and I start
walking and she's monitoring my heart
and she goes okay you're good so I
played that night the next night was
tonight so I know that yeah while he's
in the hospital
skip one day and then played that next
night and here is Chris Pronger just two
nights ago a stunned audience here in
Detroit as a 97 mile an hour slap shot
hit him in the chest and he collapsed to
the ground his heart skipped a beat and
folks when that happens it's called
commotion cordis and boy was that a
frightening moment dude so you've been
through hell and with the I think
concussions because the I think is a
separate thing yeah I remember going to
see you after a game I remember I'm not
gonna say this guy cuz he's an owner of
one of the he's now the GM of don't say
his name
GM of one of the NHL teams yes but he
was like the Joker in one of the locker
rooms or one of the team's you played
and he used to take in the showers he'd
take a bar of soap and he'd swipe one of
the guy's butt cheeks and go my ATMs not
work I remember beer just it was just
chaos people laugh and a joke and it
just it seems like today more people
players are more serious because I'm
friends with some of the guys I don't
really go to a lot ton of hockey games
but I remember for instance the Blues
going in a locker room after like yeah
but come [ __ ] down no one gives a
[ __ ] come down there and it's like Rudy
PO check and it's [ __ ] the old guys
and pop Dimitra to meet you god bless a
man that was at the [ __ ] hole
horrible sorry he was a tremendous
player he's from was it rusher Slovakia
lochia Slovakia one of the best players
in the blue is right he was a scorer yep
and he just he was playing in overseas
in his plane crash and he died like what
five years ago just a travesty but but
back nine years ago oh man but I yeah I
just remember the locker rooms just
filled with joy and fawn and life and
you know I guess that's probably hard
there are there's like had ice all over
your body
I'm not kidding it was so uncomfortable
you had like Ryan I'm not talking just
like an ice pack like us [ __ ] like
we're on our neck oh my neck you know
I've had some surgeries these guys were
like they had these they have these cold
things were they called the cold dips
the all are you the tubs cold hot cold
tubs they just sitting there for like 15
20 minutes of on ice they have ice
wrapped around each body part every game
every game did you hate that you get
used to it these routines maintenance
yeah yeah i all i put ice bags on both
my knees every day even when you're not
playing no wow
practice every day i heat him up every
day and i cool him down every day did
you ever you like Quinn's ville right
yeah he was great yeah great coach went
on to win with the Blackhawks yeah
by the way how happy were you of course
I remember talking to you when the Blues
finally won it I mean I know you wish
you were on the ice then but you it's
great for the city great 82 years right
two years 52 years yeah it that was an
emotional day huh yeah it was you know
it's just great to see you got a lot of
longtime fans a lot of a lot of great
people you love their still yeah a lot
of great people come through the
organization know that that are still
part of it and and you know I think just
to see the that's a baseball city it's
you know obviously the Rams left just
the emot-- the emotion and and you know
what to see the city show as well as it
did after winning nobody burned anything
nobody [ __ ] trashed anything
everybody just got drunk that's it they
just had a great time right hey we
played in this the alum you just got
inducted to the Hall of Fame a couple
years ago three years ago
four years ago four years ago you're
inducted into the Hall of Fame Congrats
my Frank you [ __ ] brilliant
we played me it was an all-star game as
a legends game before the all-star game
as me yeah you in a bunch I was so
honored to be able to play and this is
like Dennis well that was a top 100 top
100 yes and I got to play in that yes
and you know you were okay you were okay
that was all right
but you know you know it's funny as
Bieber was in the locker room with me
and he's like hey man you're in
Smallville Mike yeah he's like yeah yeah
how is that girl Kristin Kreuk yeah Lana
yeah she's really pretty
yeah she was I got to kiss her he's like
oh yeah cool
yeah so let me ask you this is the I
want the right real answer okay before
you played were you like [ __ ] for
Justin Bieber the [ __ ] little twerp I
don't like this [ __ ] kid or were you
like indifferent I didn't care and then
afterward gentle more respect for him
what was it uh no I didn't really care
one way or the other I was just having
fun and he was out there trying to score
goals so we were like [ __ ] dad he's not
scoring here I really wanted to score
badly him by the way the [ __ ] never
passed no cuz he wanted a score so
pissed all the guys in the on the on the
on the on the bench I was playing with
like the best there was his name from
the Oilers if it's McDavid Jesus he's a
nice guy he doesn't say a [ __ ] word
he's like and I haven't seen that guy
pass the puck once but it was great
Gretzky was coaching us amused coaching
your team I mean it was a tree that was
live did were you do you that was the
last time I had a pair of skates on was
it painful for you no did you have any
kind of pain or no it was fun cuz I you
know what the only reason I played was
three weeks before that I played an
alumni Winter Classic in st. Louis but
now you're done done what play you done
playing if I haven't put my [ __ ] on
since what did you do this be honest if
I book the ice next time you come in
town just me and you and maybe a goalie
just go out there and pass around and
shoot not a [ __ ] chance why cuz I
don't skate it hurts my knees like bad
yeah they're bone-on-bone and the angle
with the skates that's that scene you
fix that yeah I can get new knees once
you get new knees and then we'll play
look.this then I'll be able to skate
with us let me go and do that so I can
ski listen I got a little surprise for
you I asked a couple of guys it was
last-minute but I had a couple guys call
so we could always edit this but let's
just see what let's see what Jamie
McLennan has to say all right yeah the
message is for Chris Pronger this is
your million-dollar bartender calling
Jamie McClellan's aka noodles I heard a
vicious rumor that you're talking to
Rosie listen I just had a couple
questions I don't know how far you're
gonna let everyone peek but I wonder if
you should tell the story of us getting
no-sleep and then you showing up into
that breakfast for about five 500 people
the people in st. Louis and I slept for
40 minutes and I don't even know if you
slept at all Chris but my table had
nobody there so I could just pass out
and sit there you unfortunately had
being the captain you had to make a
speech and at one point I looked over in
the other couple kids and headlocks and
you were roughing the box
maybe we tell that story not too many
questions for you but if you're not nice
to me maybe I'll go on Rosie's podcast
and tell a bunch of stories
you're a good man Chris when you're
sleeping later all right so that's Jamie
Clinton he was the backup goalie who was
a good goalie he was my million dollar
bartender what does that mean he was
paid a million dollars as salary and
essentially he was my bartender and he's
me drew I was his job was to we you know
we'd go out obviously a lot and at the
odd one oh yeah and he would be my
bartender
I can imagine you on the bench chirpin
at your own team at your own players
what the [ __ ] was that right in the
front you missed that were you that guy
uh at times did you ever see guys my
[ __ ] fault that was my bad my bad
yeah yeah not often though any guys that
didn't like you that you like he didn't
like me um or they have to learn to like
you they don't have a choice they must
like yeah you know I think something
they didn't like practicing against me
early on it was not very nice to
practice against a little rough in
practice I listen folks this is another
you want me to tell that story or do you
want me to what store the store when
you're hammered when you're going to the
yeah
do you want me to tell that story go
ahead alright so we went out a couple
couple other by the buddies from LA come
in to st. Louis so we show them the town
right so we take them out we have a 6:00
a.m. breakfast with the blues and we we
got home from the bar at 5:30 and
apparently he went to sleep I just was
like well [ __ ] I better not I won't wake
up
so I put my suit on brush my teeth boom
out the door get over to this breakfast
I'm sitting with the team president and
you he's probably reek like alcohol had
to have just wreaked sitting with a
couple major sponsors I'm still crushed
and now I got to make a speech I'm
talking to these kids I got these kids
I'm taking pictures I'm signing
autographs having a good time
and noodles is just staring at me like
how the [ __ ] is this guy doing this and
I'm just got my game face on we leave to
go to now we got practice we gotta go to
practice now I'm just we're still cut I
get to practice and Joe's like hey are
you okay to practice oh we had we had to
do power play we had to get there early
because we're working the power play and
noodles had to be the [ __ ] goalie as
a backup you had to be the guy the
shooter - oh my god oh my god guess how
many pucks he stopped
zero zero [ __ ] saves Joe Pez he was
just like so afterwards you know we're
moving the puck round or whatever and
then afterwards Luis and I are skating
around a joke comes up it goes holy [ __ ]
boys that must have been a good one last
night
it's okay to practice like oh yeah we're
good
we'll get by again that night no God no
no no we didn't play for a few days I
thank God no oh there and by the way
another one with noodles i won
so in my contract this is when you could
do this
I had a bonus for winning the plus/minus
award
what means if he is so guys out there if
he's let in more goals than he hasn't so
he's a negative if he more goals have
gone in if it's a positive when you're
on the ice when I go scored yeah it's a
plus yes so my fine my five-on-five not
when you're shorthand and her power play
right I had a huge bonus for that and I
want it when you go plus ten I was plus
that's ridiculous so I won I won the
award so I got a million dollar bonus so
I'm like all right I'm gonna take
everybody over for dinner we go to Dre's
here in town and we're actually out west
so we take go out for dinner have a
great night show up to practice the next
day now Joel knows we're going out or
you know we're having a great time it's
team-building chemistry chemistry get to
practice and it's I've this ring I don't
know where the hell it was it was not
where they practice now it was a piece
of [ __ ] it was a shitty isip Lexon Rosco
it might have been it was a shitty rank
Jenny ice was terrible it was like this
and we get out there and I'm a little
under the weather and again Joel Joel
saddles up next to me is rake hey kid
you okay can you practice I go no I'm
good I can get by I'll just go to the
back of the line oh that's the trick you
always start at the back of the line and
as you work forward keep going to the
back then you get like two away and you
just scooch back to the back again oh
yeah see you never even play you never
have to go anywhere
a commuter big [ __ ] I'll go quickly
one is I was just roommate for five
years and he was always at the head of
the curve of stuff so he started
drinking these protein shakes and just
had the worst ass in the world would
absolutely destroy the room the protein
well and I was the unfortunate person
that had to sit in that room
next thing is ask him about a special
MVP season not only did it with the
league MVP a heart trophy but it won the
north's not sure if anyone's ever done
that maybe Bobby Orr with a special year
he controlled games from the back end
but he was funny and then I also follows
pretty funny that was as you know really
mean on the ice and I always found it
funny on the action cam when you would
make grown ass top hockey players show
fear and apologize to him and he would
respond with the fact that he is not
afraid to take a suspension he loved
that line he would tell guys all the
time I'll take a suspension on you and
but he's a fun guy to be around a lot of
people realize you know think that he's
so serious all the time but he was he
liked your joke wrong and bearish you
guys loved the game as much as him so I
learned a lot about being a leader from
him but yeah you can rip on him about
those couple things I mean obviously
these guys have a lot of love and
respect for you you probably don't talk
to a lot of these guys much yeah I see I
see him once more okay I catch
you know you know what it is when you
get friends it's like me and you you
pick up where you left off is this you
don't you know if you're if you're
really good friends with somebody you
don't have to talk to him every day you
catch up when you can catch up and you
hope that right here a little you pick
up right where you left off people who
get really like you know some I have
some family members or some friend
gorgeous like oh you don't call me back
oh you don't do this it's like it's like
a it's not because I'm very sensitive
yeah yeah people get sensitive yeah so I
only felt bad so two jammers point I
only felt bad for half a second once we
were playing la remember big Steve
McKenna oh yeah it's like 6-9 or
whatever the guy yeah and he was trying
to run around and be an idiot who's more
of a fighter right yeah and he's trying
to run me and I'm like get the [ __ ] out
of here and an end to his point I'm like
stop [ __ ] coming near me or I will
[ __ ] stick you right in the eye and
he looked at me I go I'm not [ __ ]
kidding
and so the play goes on you know we
change and he's kind of looking at me
all of a sudden he's back I don't know
why he was on the ice when I was out
there but whatever he was on the ice and
I went the puck went near him I don't
know how and I went to lift his stick
and I missed I [ __ ] hit him right on
the eyebrow almost took his eye out and
for like half a second I was like oh and
then I was like I [ __ ] told you
[ __ ] told you I was gonna get you
what did he do he was like holy [ __ ]
guys for like half a second I caught
myself I was almost like oh sorry
and there was again no [ __ ] you hey look
I could talk to you for [ __ ] ever
this is already awesome but I want to
finish with this you're a family guy now
you're a dad of three yes sir you've
been a husband for I'm gonna get I'm
gonna say 21 years it is almost 1919 yes
okay married in 101 I thought was
earlier what do you do how do you do
things differently than your parents did
where they let you just kind of it's a
different world
it's a different country and it's a
different it's a different world
different country different everything
right so what do you do have generate
how hard is it to be a dad how leaning
on are you on them do you make sure they
understand how to be grateful to you do
you ever talk to me all this I we talked
about that stuff being grateful and
appreciative for what we have for what
we're able to provide them you know I
think for us we're pretty hat we're very
hands-on parents were we you know while
I might be out here right now but were
you around a lot around a lot I say do
you honestly do you say Jack I love you
buddy
I love you yeah do you say I love you
their kids yeah is it easier to say to
the girl cuz you're tough guys a little
daddy's girl no hey no I tell them you
do I love you yeah you say hey I love
you a little [ __ ] do you have to add
something to it
Oh every night you know when I put them
we put say Lauren love you to give her a
kiss good night yeah sometimes you're
the kind of guy that when you get any
kind of affection I think like me I'm
I'm not the most affectionate guy in the
world yeah me neither but it's hard it's
cuz it's hard for me and I try but I
have to be really comfortable to have to
I don't know I just don't feel
comfortable for some reason maybe
because I saw the dysfunction with my
family I don't want to do this so when
it does happen it's probably a really
nice thing you know Lauren spray like Oh
Chris did that and he gave me a kiss on
the cheek oh I guess that's good for the
next three years where I have a problem
is when I'm told to do it
yeah nobody wants it no well then I'm
late when she tells me you have to do
this I'm like I don't have to do [ __ ]
anything you you can't tell me to do it
now you ruined it now you ruined it I
was gonna do it that's the thing if you
were like putting it in the calendar be
nice to Lauren and the kids on April 4th
that's different
she doesn't she doesn't know if you're
gonna have her dude she's like hey you
know but you don't note to self well it
does go a long way I'll tell you what
little things go a long way like I have
a difficult time talking to my mother I
love her but I don't like her
but you know I called her on her
birthday and I talked to her for a good
20 minutes and I and I gave her
undivided attention I didn't I didn't
veer off and and sports and I said you
know I'm gonna talk to my mother on her
birthday and I'm gonna ask her how it
was and let her talk and no matter how
annoyed I get I'm gonna stay with it
yeah at the end I said all right well
mom I got a couple meetings and I really
enjoyed talking to you and I want you to
know I want you to have a happy birthday
and I love you and that was it and it
was for her yeah and also felt good yeah
it felt good so I'm just say I'm not
telling you what to do but just every
once in a while it does help a little
active kind of act of gratitude yes
those things [ __ ] go a long way they
do do you ever say it to your parents
you ever say what's wrong yeah they're
getting old now yeah well when they can
hear me they both deaf now are they well
they were deaf when I knew my dad is
pretty well and my mom is deaf in one
ear
your dad's completely deaf pretty much
does he know sign language he's no he
reads lips and he can hear kind of but
he's gonna get the cochlear implants and
does work it's supposed to help I don't
know we're gonna find out that'd be nice
huh
yeah so if that works then he can hear
again but you make a joke you got to say
it four [ __ ] times it's no longer
funny and now you're annoyed yeah you
know it's just thing about for him I
want know so every time you know me and
my brother were talking I'm like just
think how mad we get how painful it is
for him knowing that you're getting
pissed off that he can't [ __ ] hear
you yeah you know what this is could be
a job for the bartender yeah for
McLennan yeah you have him come along
with you you tell a joke I mean you had
you leave McLennan stays there with your
dad get some drinks and it tells him a
joke for the next there you go I always
have an open door policy in st. Louis
radical always coming stay with ya
yeah you still live in the same place I
got a room for you you still have that
golf game in the basement no no I get a
new place is it nicer it is and you're
working for the Florida Panthers yes sir
and what your scouting senior advisor to
the GM so I kind of do everything so if
I ever wanna go to game it's easy yeah
just call me but you have to pay for
away games right hockey players have to
good thing yeah home games you're all
right and you know people probably and
most people don't know
they don't know that but if you go to a
game and you ask your friend for a
ticket people go hey you know what's not
baseball where they get I'm doing a
ticket because they can't fill a stadium
yeah
hockey arenas are tough so when you
asked me hey can you get me tickets to
this Hawk you can only the players
actually have to pay for the way games
or you're paying for it evencio d and oh
by the way I've done this I've left
tickets somebody said hey can you leave
me tickets I go yeah they're gonna be Co
D they'll be left when you don't pay for
them they're charging me yeah
there's your they're setting them out of
their allotment and taking them off the
books if you don't pick them up and pay
for them I'm getting charged for them do
you hear this guys everybody outside we
just want you to know this this is
really important and I've been [ __ ] by
a couple people thousands of dollars
because they didn't want to pay for
their [ __ ] tickets you know who you
are [ __ ] you know this has been a
roadie did you learn a lot Ryan I did
lots of swearing I apologize you don't
know we get tender ears yeah yeah no I
don't know how these podcasts work I
didn't know how real you wanted me to be
dude this has been great like I think
you're one of the best hockey players
ever lived you're your great friend even
though I don't see a lot I always think
about you when when do you think about
me when you're on the throne up there
well some should I should I tell people
that this being the first time I've been
invited your house
I had to christen your toilet that's it
that he walks in the house I gave him a
hug
five seconds I got a pinch a loaf he
walks up to my back after my master it's
gone it's just the score Celine has been
just destroyed you know what I do think
of me here's how I think of you right
now as I'm interviewing you I everyday I
look at Pronger your ass jerseys always
been there here's to many more good
years for the both of us
your Bubba Chris Pronger 44 that Jersey
was given to me in 98 probably that's
the MVP Jersey dude has 2000 and it's a
real was it yeah mm but that's a real
Jersey that's like you off your back
there's markings of the stick on it yeah
so you know that's a that's a good one
man I really appreciate that so I do
think of you I think I think of you
fondly I know you and Lauren have a
business together - and we do talk about
that for a second
the company is called well inspired
travels it is a luxury travel business
something that I've been fortunate
enough to do and we've been fortunate
enough to do as a family is travel and
and go on these great trips and now kids
are a little bit older you know Lauren
ultimately started it in the beginning
and brought me on board and I love to
travel I love seeing new places I love
how you feel when you're on vacation you
know the happiness and joy that it can
bring you and you know coming from the
injuries in different places that I've
been at it kind of brings you back and
re-energize your revitalizes your mind
and your body and spirit well do where
can they find you on the Instagram I am
at D Chris Pronger just on Instagram now
yeah and Atwell inspired travels is our
company and Lauren can be fired on what
Instagram that's that's hers well that's
ours
that's yours we're together here
together well check that out listen well
inspire travels calm and add well
inspire travels yes it's interesting
stuff on Instagram so check check that
out man Chris Brown I love you buddy
thanks for letting me be inside of you
[Music]
you